[Music]
[Music]
us
humans have dominated the planet for
millennia
residing comfortably at the top of the
food chain
we pride ourselves with our technology
built
walls to shield us from the dangers
lurking outside
we cultivate and shape nature
manipulated
to fulfill our needs and from the safety
and comfort of our territories
we gaze upon the beauty of nature from
afar
from a distance the vast landscapes of
hyrule
are stunning serene calming even
but looks can be deceiving strip away
the comforts of our civilization
and the average hylian will soon find
out the hardships
of surviving in the wild out here
instinct and knowledge of the land
dictate the chances of survival
which resources are valuable or safe for
consumption
and which are better left untouched how
to brave the diverse and harsh climates
and perhaps more importantly how to
interact with the many creatures
roaming the wastes hyrule is absolutely
brimming with life
from the smallest of rodents to the
majestic wild horses of the plain
wolf packs bonded together in search for
prey
the intimidating and fierce grizzly bear
some friendly some hostile all
living in harmony with their environment
[Music]
but there is something else living here
as well
a species which stands out from the rest
of the animal kingdom
due to a general higher intelligence
coordination
and thus intimidation factor so much so
that they are classified in a category
of their own
separate from the other wildlife you and
i
know them as monsters fitting really
it's a term often used by us humans to
describe
something we don't fully understand
something
vile or cruel which sparks fear
and seemingly operates with no
conscience or emotion
savage primitive but is that truly the
full picture
or is there more to these critters than
meets the eye
perhaps misunderstood even today we take
a closer look at one such creature
a familiar face found in every corner of
hyrule
from the highest of mountains to the
grassy plains of nicuda
the bokoblin for the last weeks
we have studied these beings extensively
from a safe distance
analyze their behavioral patterns
traditions
and interactions with their surroundings
bokoblins
are naturally hostile to humans cross
their paths will get in the way of their
prey
and they won't hesitate to use brute
force
amongst their own kind and even other
species of monsters however
they are very much social creatures like
ourselves
it is extraordinarily rare to encounter
a lone bokoblin
on your travels rather they prefer to
operate in groups or tribes
making them even harder to approach or
interact with
like us they have realized the concept
of strength in numbers
but we need to learn more taking notes
and spying on them from a safe distance
doesn't grant us a true and honest
insight into their true nature
in order to truly understand the
bulgoblin we must attempt to make
contact
live like them and learn the nature of
their ways
through close interaction but how
their hostility towards our species
serves as roadblock to conduct a proper
study
that is why in the lead-up to our quest
for knowledge
we have devised a strategy to overcome
the barriers separating us from them
using the latest in stealth technology
we have conducted a clever disguise
based on our current understanding of
the creature
one which hopefully will allow us to
fool our subjects
into accepting us as one of their own
but
looks aren't everything of course body
language is equally as important
to achieve our goal of blending in
notice
the hunched over starts arms stretched
out to the side
to mimic the neutral position of the
bokoblin
this is an essential part of the
disguise
break character and one might risk the
disguise falling apart
of which the consequences could be dire
all that is left now is to wait for the
break of dawn
as tomorrow we put our strategy to the
ultimate test
[Music]
sunrise a new day dawns in hyrule
and we are ready to start our research
for our experiment we have chosen the
great plateau
as the most viable location its secluded
nature
acts as its own little ecosystem
separate from the rest of land
bokoblin's camps are plentiful in this
area
some small some large some seek shelter
while others prefer to sleep under the
stars
our target is this camp right here up on
the ridge
close to the ruins of the temple of time
it's one of the medium-sized camps out
here
consisting of a total of three
inhabitants tucked away
on this remote cliffside a perfect way
to study our subjects undisturbed
carefully we make our approach please
remember
that this is a high risk operation
performed by a trained professional
thus we must insist that one does not
attempt this on their own
it seems the bokoblins have spotted us
this is the moment of truth so far so
good
no signs of hostility yet instead
fascination and curiosity reign supreme
who is this stranger crossing into our
domain
why is he here after some careful
assessment
the bokoblins returned to their daily
routine
seemingly unfazed by their otherworldly
visitor
the disguise works but we are far from
getting accepted into their ranks
right away we notice a hierarchy within
the clan
notice the dark grey skin tone and the
war paint on the body of this particular
specimen
a clear sign that he is calling the
shots around here
the other two rotate shifts fulfilling
their duties in service of the tribe
hunting guard duty cooking
it's a fascinating display of teamwork
really
one of the first things we learn is that
bokoblins
don't seem to bother with names well not
vocally anyway for convenience sake
we've decided to assign each their own
name
to avoid confusion grey their chief in
command
red and larry
that night we weren't allowed to sleep
at the campfire
gray simply wouldn't allow it who can
blame them really
in their eyes we are an intruder
a strange and unusual visitor from
foreign lands
in general the different tribes living
on the plateau
don't seem to interact much they mostly
stick to their own kind
respecting each other's territory it's
something hyrule's developed races
could take notes from our histories are
rich
with the desire to expand our lands
to take it by any means necessary even
by force
bokoblins don't seem to share this lust
for power
as long as there's food on the table a
place to sleep
and companionship they are content to
live simple
lives out here in the wild tomorrow
we must find a way to win the hearts of
the tribe
and gain the trust of their leadership
let's hope our attempt is fruitful
at the break of dawn while the others
are out hunting
we gather some materials as a show of
goodwill to the tribe
mushrooms fruits and anything else the
land has to offer
hopefully this gesture will ease their
minds a bit
food has apparently been scarce as of
late
and today the hunting party once again
returns empty-handed upon laying eyes on
our offering
the group seems rather hesitant at first
but
quickly realizes that any food is better
than nothing at this point
despite our gift grey still seems
suspicious of us
however larry has seemingly opened up to
us a bit
as we indulged in some brief
conversation
at night we were even allowed to stay
for a while
and join in on the chitchat of course
their language is not one we currently
understand so some nods and some basic
hand signals will have to do
for now but alas one offering won't
reward us a spot at the warm campfire
just yet
and we've returned to our secluded
sleeping spot
under the trees to get some
well-deserved rest
for the next few days we repeat the same
daily routine
of looking after the camp while the
others are out hunting
we gather up materials polish and repair
weaponry
cook up some basic food and try to keep
the campsite clean
we continue to bond with our new found
friend
and we even got to join larry on guard
duty
which was a nice change of pace from the
usual busy work
at night we routinely join the group for
some small talk
until we are once again sent back to our
usual spot
as the outsider we still are until
one morning we are woken up by none
other than
grey who offers us to join the hunting
party today
it seems our hard work has finally paid
off
with almost a week without a successful
hunt the situation is getting more dire
and it seems even grey realizes they
will all need the help they can get
this might be our chance to finally
prove ourselves
as not to lose daylight we immediately
set out for the nearby forest
the ball roaming these woods have
dwindled in numbers
and are more skittish than ever before
making them harder and harder to catch
in order to cover more ground the group
decided to split up
gray and red try their luck up north
while larry
joins us as we continue westward into
the dense
forest maukoblins have found many
different ways to hunt their prey
some resort to a stealthy approach while
others
give chase and try to corner their prey
like a pack of wolves
some have even been seen riding various
animals
to take advantage of their speed they
craft their own weaponry
like wooden bows shields clubs and
spears
and although simplistic and primitive in
design
they get the job done when it comes to
survival in the wild
the fact that they are able to tame
wildlife and craft
weapons shows that they are far more
evolved than many had initially guessed
but we must keep our focus on the task
ahead
if we managed to bring home something
good
we might finally be accepted into the
tribe
so far the hunt has been fruitless
larry decides to search along the
cliffside
while we wander deeper into the forest
it looks like this might again turn into
a failed hunt
until finally a wild boar rears its head
amongst the tall grass this is it
our one chance
[Music]
[Music]
do
that night we feasted after weeks of no
success
this meal came as a gift from the
heavens
the mood of the tribe that night is one
of great joy and celebration
larry and red express their thanks and
even grey
seems to have changed his tone for the
better our many days of hard labor
bonding discipline and today's triumph
has earned us a spot at the campfire
gone are the days
of being an exile in the days ahead we
continue to hunt
gather converse and bond with this
fascinating species
the tribe's acceptance is a reward in
and of itself
but what really matters is the data
we've collected during
our journey unfortunately this is also
where our paths must diverge as much as
we've enjoyed our time with our
newfound friends we must return to our
own kind it's only a matter of time
until one day
they may find out who we really are
saying goodbye is something they
probably won't understand
it's a human thing after all instead
we shall slip away quietly into the
night
and hope that the tribe will understand
our decision
who knows we might meet again someday
perhaps we may even be able to make
contact without the use of disguises and
deception but for now our adventure
ends here
our research has shown that despite
their more primitive and simplistic
lifestyle the bokoblins have earned the
right to roam these lands
for centuries they have adapted and used
their exceptional survival skills
to thrive and while they are still
hostile to us
humans can we really blame them
monsters we call them but perhaps from
their perspective
we are the monsters here disturbing the
peace and crossing into their territory
without a care
for anything other than ourselves the
various tribes
living here respect each other's
boundaries they don't go to war with one
another
over territory or fight amongst
themselves
they have their own language culture
customs
and traditions they hunt and tame
wildlife
and craft tools like we do though
outshined by our intellect and
technology
there is still plenty to be learned from
the creatures roaming the wild
and perhaps one day we might be able to
establish a more friendly relationship
with them
if we put our prejudice aside
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you